[Music]
this morning on the dish a four-year
journey that took an 18-year-old british
girl from her parents kitchen to the
creation of a highly successful bakery
in their new book bread song kitty tate
and her father al shared the recipes and
love that brought their family back from
the brink mts tayab went to the english
town of waddlington to meet them
it may just be the smallest town in
england but residents of wattlington
will tell you
one of the greatest things to come here
since sliced bread is the orange bakery
where al and kitty tate a father and
daughter
bake shop has developed a cult following
as they experiment with ingredients to
make the perfect bake
this is wild garlic pesto wild garlic
paste we went foraging yesterday for the
wild garlic you foraged we did the first
time we foraged for it we managed to
pick grass okay
it's got quite a cake yeah oh
yeah
oh that is so good
you can definitely taste the garlic yeah
you're not gonna go kissing anywhere
[Laughter]
the tate's journey to master baker
started in what was one of kitty's
darkest periods in 2018 at just 14 years
old she fell into a deep depression i
couldn't get out of bed and i couldn't
function and
i couldn't even i can eat and there were
all these different things going on in
my head that i just didn't understand
and i didn't know why they were there i
mean dad this must have been so hard as
a parent to to see in your job
yeah it was
it was horrifying
quite simply
kitty's depression was so crippling she
couldn't go to school anymore so al left
his job at oxford university to care for
her
so
what helped you
get through the days one day i watched
dad make a loaf of bread and he got a
bowl and he mixed flour water salt a
tiny bit of yeast and he put a cheetah
over the top and then the next morning
he took the tea towel off and he put it
into a tin and he baked it but it was
this really lovely golden life and it
was so simple
but it just made me feel safe
and that in that moment really i just i
fell head over heels in love with brett
a love that led kitty to bake loaf
after loaf
after loaf a skill which quickly
inspired her to launch her very first
pop-up and about half an hour before the
pop-up the whole town was just empty it
was so nerve-wrecking and slightly
heartbreaking and then i opened the door
and there's about 60 people stretching
all the way down the high street and we
sold out of everything within i think it
was 28 minutes wow 28 minutes and
what was going through your mind
not a lot but at the end i suddenly
realized that this i could i could do
this
yeah this wasn't something that was
helping me get through depression
anxiety this is what i wanted to do
so kitty and al turned to kickstarter
with this one-of-a-kind very
orange-themed fundraising video
within 48 hours we had hit our target
but they also needed a business plan and
who better to ask for advice than the
founders of san francisco's beloved
tartine bakery so i managed to track
down chad robertson and his wife liz
perez so i started write letters just
saying that i love that book how much it
helped me and then one day i looked at
my instagram and i saw that they were
following me
and then chad sent me a message and liz
pruitt when i did the crowd funding put
it onto her instagram story and i'm
still so thankful to them gratitude
which inspired kitty and al to author
their own book of recipes called bread
song
a title inspired by the snap crackle and
pop of bread fresh out of the oven
one of their most popular breads is made
using one of kitty's favorite
ingredients miso the japanese fermented
soybean paste
and then one day i'll say okay i love it
so much why not just like fold it into
the dough
really beautiful like you can actually
see it in in the crumb you get this
amazing red miso swirls look you get
like a little patch here and it makes it
bread incredibly moist too right i mean
miso and a loaf of bread they just not
something i would ever even think about
you can just see that right through
there
that beautiful miso just layered through
[Music]
kitty's sense of humor is baked into
several of her creations
including these
here we've got corgi butter butts corgi
butter butt
as in but
but
i'm a corgi
because you have recorded because i have
a cookie so i have a queen's
exactly so it's this really soft fluffy
brioche and then with a bit of pearl
sugar which is like rock salt for like
rock sugar and choc chips for pores
oh it
is you go hey
how cute is that so cute
this is so good
i mean it's just good
[Laughter]
it's chewy it's sweet
the sugar just really gives it a nice
crunch to it i mean just
it also kind of tastes a bit like
childhood right for kitty the crippling
depression she endured as a 14 year old
will never be entirely gone and
awareness she finds strength
this whole journey started because of
mental health what do you want to say to
those who might be struggling it can get
better and i don't know exactly when but
i know that it will and actually all the
stuff that is you're going through it
does make you stronger because it means
that you can understand others it's just
something that is extra like an extra
flavor to the bread
for sebia saturday morning emphio's tab
waddlington oxfordshire
we love her we love her we love her how
joyful i mean to see that and that it
was depression that brought her to bread
in the first place her father
leaving his job for her
success success success whatever it
takes that's beautiful family i mean
she's just you just want to just eat her
up you know she's so adorable i want to
eat the bread i was just going to say i
want to eat up the bread you could eat
her or the bread and the bread yeah
fantastic she really is nice job